yeah welcome to this video playing
against an i am here from Germany then
in phone yeah cutter Sicily in here yeah
he always place the sea 526 stuff yeah
quindi for some possibility i'll wait
let's let's try it let's try let's try
this and see what he what is coming up
with let's try to transpose to earth
miss more honest as always funny okay
I'm um maybe maybe I can irritate him
with with this move we are probably
Knight a5 is to be avoided okay let's
just just develop it's not so clear I am
this one I want to say it's not so clear
how is going to develop his pieces maybe
he wants to really play g5 so not
ridiculous but I have some some pressure
against the center kb should be six
yeah of course he's tending to take it
can also take a six and here i don't
know let's let's take this it's a bit
dumb bit complicated but i hope that
that i have some play against the center
h2porn the h2o bishop is some pressure
pressurizing if I find if I take now
probably take maybe take with the bishop
night-night c4 maybe if it takes f3 I
can take be too also maybe this isn't so
great actually now that I think about it
and maybe I can just recapture okay this
I didn't consider at all just hands me
the bishops but okay it's probably not
so so bad Bishop takes yeah probably
but ok it's not bad he's got this active
rook yes hmm the question is yeah
probably ate my mistake I must take not
much else to do ok that's just the
techie 5 see how he protects this yeah
this is us I suspected this it didn't
protect it at all but now I've got them
to bishops in an open position and all
my pieces are active Bishop d6s am.sin
this one idea maybe onda should be 6am
he's going to pin me ok I want to make
sure that I'm not mated on the back rank
and it also takes away squares at five
mostly rock d 7 is the move that I want
to play and I couldn't play before
because of rupee one at least this would
have been yeah forcing me to retreat
something and I don't want to retreat at
this position this is what let's go
forward here rock on d 7 now just
attacking e7 this is terrible for like
really okay so um the ship d 646
attacking f6
taking f6 of course not attacking f8 and
f7 I this is the problem yeah maybe okay
yeah maybe he can Oh interesting I
thought might be a DAC chua Lee but ok
this is this is a possibility look II
one look you want to prevent this yeah
looks a bit unnatural maybe we should be
three and actually yeah there should be
three now look III awesome idea
you can give this night f4 check but I
just move the king yet it doesn't do
much I think King g3 and if he exchanges
then he's got his only active pieces off
the board and the look doesn't have a
square I mean where is it going if
everything covered and don't really see
a missed a good one ya know f8 saying if
you move the roof does of seven and the
whole position is crumbling ok but just
Rock c7.r saw stake here first take
you can also just take a seven I mean
why not or is this some pattern and why
is he thinking even I don't understand
it let's just grab it why not night
takes i'm a maybe i'm just flies maybe
I'm just blind I still thought night
takes the sun direct with I mean I'm
winning but it's not like I'm a piece up
or something I look e7 yeah this is
strong this is strong I'm just attacking
this piece and where's he going if you
go see I just a fluke c7 attacking
attacking this attacking this and it's
it's gone yeah yeah I had to head active
pieces simply somehow this is the c-4 I
mean before just if he is somehow able
to avoid this before move then and still
I have this Bishop on h2 I mean it at
xe5 but just imagine he would manage
king king do fine f6 or something and
then this is thing is biting on granite
and now we have an exchange against the
c3 porn which is weak anyway and now
look at it I mean all my pieces are good
now this Bishop is good this Bishop is
good and the looks are excellently
placed and here i mean probably have
something more forceful but just
clearing the back rank is good this
would have been nice but he's got this
means and now i need to retreat a piece
and I don't want to retreat anything
here so this is why I went g4
and now i have just King g2 on the check
and what is he moving those nights are
not mobile there they are basically
glued to each other cannot move and yeah
this is terrible to defend I mean
especially for you will play yeah thanks
for watching